[Music]
naturally in the wine industry we have
good years we have bad years
last year we had the fires major fires
here in california in napa valley
and then this is the second year of
drought so it's been rough just from
that aspect it is certainly difficult
times
not only we have labor shortages but at
the same time
there's scarcity and supply and there's
an abundance of demand
business owners like winemaker
malakamrani are facing three main
pressures on how they price their
products
high demand rising costs of labor and
rising costs of supplies whether omrani
and others like him absorb these costs
or pass them on to consumers determines
the course of inflation in the us
economy the us economy is made up of
literally
hundreds of millions of individual
workers businesses and employers and
inflation is really the output of what
all those hundreds of millions of people
financially are deciding in the
transactions with each other and their
own decisions
these decisions have big consequences
for business owners
eating the rising costs they're facing
could destroy their profit margin but
passing them on could drive customers
away
so this is the equivalent of a glass of
wine
vice wine is a mid-sized napa valley
winery we produce about 25 000 cases a
year typically we are
a little bit under what the typical
price point for napa valley wine will be
the house tier we are between
22.33 bucks for our single vineyard
reserved here that starts at 38 dollars
and it goes all the way up to 69.
like many businesses right now amrani
says he's experiencing strong demand for
his product
but he's facing a lot of obstacles to
meet that demand
we are in a perfect storm where kind of
all the elements things that we never
had to worry about are becoming really
difficult to source
[Music]
it's been very hard to source labor
since the start of pandemic
it's kind of getting harder this year
the 15 minimum wage
really kind of doesn't apply to napa
because we've been paying here 20 to 22
dollars pre-pandemic and now since we
can't find labor we are in the upper 20s
to lower 30s just for
basic vineyard labor or cellular labor
glass has been particularly difficult to
source i will say generic glass mold
that used to take me a text message
maybe a phone call or an email to order
now takes me 20 to 40 hours on average
to find
i have so many of them
wise class suppliers it's like
you're going to be talking to 12 people
all the freaking time
thank you for calling west coast bottles
how are you
hey i'm good cynthia how you been
what is it i don't have any good news
for you today
oh shoot how much are you selling this
blindfold um
you know for the cab we're 29 29 bucks
and then when i do find the glass
after spending a long time looking for
it then
i'm paying 30 to 50 percent more
bringing a container out of china of
glass a year ago would be somewhere
around three to four thousand dollars
today we're north of 12 to 15 000
she wouldn't even tell me the price on
the phone that's
how
bad it is i wouldn't be surprised if she
doubles the price it's she's saying it's
all because of the
shipping
even cardboard has been hard to source i
didn't expect that the card world be an
issue especially generic craft cardboard
that doesn't have anything printed on it
the prices dramatically went up no less
than 50 in some instances
the only thing that may
help ease
the difficulties on the supply chain
is a lower demand and i really don't see
the demand slowing down anytime soon
so we know that a big part of the
inflation process is psychological
prices uh inflation will partly depend
on what people think it will be so think
of the business that's facing an
increase in his cost
you can either decide all right these
higher costs are here to stay and i'm
going to raise the price for my
customers or he can decide you know i've
got a pretty good sense and this is a
temporary disruption and those costs are
going back a year from now if i raise my
prices now i'm going to lose market
share and it'll be for nothing because
those costs will go down a year from now
so
he's got to make that call
we're absolutely trying to swallow the
cost and
just deal with it
but because
it's not a five percent or two percent
or 10
inflation in many cases it's 40 up it
will certainly have consequences when it
comes to uh
price increases
our brand was born on the idea of making
napa valley accessible for that everyday
occasion if we are forced to raise the
prices in the house here it's almost
like we're
in a different territory appealing to a
different consumer a lot of our fans at
the vice wine i can see them remaining
loyal to us but for others they may just
not be able to afford that price
increase and they may look at other
regions besides napa valley maybe go to
a different wine regions or even
international wines versus the local
ones